Let's try the D-slider.
This device only works from left to right.
Its purpose is to drop stitches
from the main bed while maintaining the
needle positions of the needles in work.
It's used for the drop
stitch lace technique
using the ribber. With no yarn
in the needles, manually put a few needles
into B or working position and a few
needles into D or middle position.
Position the D-slider left of the needles
in work on the needle bed.
Pass it from left to right,
pressing down slightly.
Notice how the needles engage.
Also notice that the needles will
remain in their original position.
If there were stitches in work, all of
the stitches would drop off the needles.
Now, if you are going to be working short
rows or you have needles in E position or
hold position, they will also
engage with the D-slider.
If you want to work short rows with this
device, manually knit the held stitches
with Ravel cord and position
the needles back to A position.
When you're done with the transfers,
pick up the D-slider,
remove it and set it aside.
It only works from left to right.